[Musique]
à peine ouvert la carte à jouer fait
sale combles à l'intérieur tout a l'air
d'un café classique à une exception près
ici la boisson n'est pas la vedette
donc il va falloir en sauver un maximum
et pour en sauver un maximum il va
falloir les placer correctement sur
votre plateau entre collègues amis ou en
famille ici on joue de plateau
d'aventures ou de stratégie il y en a
pour tous les goûts de quoi ravir petit
et grands enfants et convivial
c'est amusant
quelque chose donc il y a un peu de la
course en même temps ce monde s'entend
bien donc c'est bien avec mes filles
avec mes enfants petits-enfants on a
toujours fait des jeux de société et
c'est des moments ensemble
partager surtout c'est des jeux qu'on a
pas chez nous forcément donc ça c'est
pas mal de pouvoir en découvrir des
nouveaux et d'avoir des personnes qui
peuvent nous expliquer les règles assez
rapidement aussi c'est pas mal parce que
des fois on comprend pas totalement les
règles quoi l'idée vient du gérant Kevin
d'évex lauréat de l'opération ma
boutique a laissé en juin 2022 il a
obtenu ce local à loyer modéré il
souhaitait ouvrir un lieu d'échange et
de convivialité l'idée est venue du fait
que moi je suis passionné de jeux de
société depuis quelques années
et je me suis rendu compte que le jeu de
société était encore assez peu
accessible malheureusement que ce soit
pour des questions de connaissances de
connaissances des règles ou de
s'imaginer que le jeu de société c'est
pour les geeks ou les enfants on essaie
de vous présenter au maximum les règles
des jeux de société de vous conseiller
en fonction de ce qui vous convient de
ce que vous aimez de ce que vous n'aimez
pas
et ensuite donc on vous aide à installer
le jeu on vous propose quelque chose à
boire ou à grignoter compter de 3,50 € à
5,50 € pour accéder aux différentes
parties de la ludothèque le café est
ouvert du mardi au samedi le Time's Up
le code naimes ou encore le dixit
n'auront donc plus de secret pour vous
[Musique]